bu bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you greetings of peace to
everybody all around the globe is tuning
in to the Deen show your friend might
have told you about the Deen show your
family matter your cousin your neighbor
and you've tuned in because you've heard
that we're talking about serious issues
purpose of life where'd you come from
where you going when you die this is the
crucial question that all of us should
be asking because death is a reality and
we don't want to take this life as a
joke because it's not a joke so we have
our next special guest who's been with
us before no man Ali Khan and the Deen
show to discuss some very serious issues
down on the minds of all the people you
got baseball football clubs night clubs
dancing all these other things is
distracting us but is that the way to go
is that the way to have peace and
happiness in life or is there more to
life find out the answers to all these
questions and more when we come back
here on the Dean show we right back
[Music]
this is the thesis betangel
[Music]
[Music]
he's been to you assalamualaikum
waalaikumsalam he's been to you as well
it's good to have you back here again on
a Deen show to be here you're actually
here alhamdulillah at the Baena
Institute we talked about it in our
first shows about the Institute that you
have teaching people the Arabic lame are
you teaching people how to be an Arab or
why you teach them Arabic well yeah
people should be Arabs all of them no no
we're trying to learn the Arabic
language as best we can here to be able
to study the Quran and actually even
beyond that study Islam more in-depth
okay before we get into that we want to
scare some people off because some
people when they hear Islam Muslims they
get turned up they get turned away so we
want to start out with some baby steps
and people when they hear about Brad
Pitt they want to know if you bought
that goldfish what JLo is doing you know
Facebook $0.50 wait Brad Pitt lot of
goldfish no I'm just saying if it was
they'd want to know so I would on a
purpose of life this is the crucial
question and we should be asking this
question why is it important to ask the
question or reflect about the purpose of
life and where you going with you down
why is it so important you know it's
most people don't ask themselves that
question and I'm very happy at the
Institute that we have people that have
made such a big sacrifice in life to try
and study here and leave careers and
studies put them on hold and you know
convince their families of making the
sacrifice which actually in and of
itself is proof that they have a very
clear picture of what their purpose in
life is and milla accept these kinds of
efforts from especially the youth that
are here but you know this question is
not something everybody cares to ask
about because the answer is difficult
and the answer requires a lot of change
in one's lifestyle right so it's
something that really on one's own time
if Allah blesses somebody if
if God blesses somebody to have the
conscious mind to think and to put the
brakes on everything else in life and
just stop and think this question will
you know lead to some very serious
consequences and some very serious
changes in life but as important as this
question is it is probably the most
ignored question in most people's lives
why does everything else seem more
important than the Creator what he wants
us to do you know these things are just
like for some people just fairy tales
you know that their parents told them
you know for some people for many people
baseball is more important football you
know who won the Super Bowl
what that girl is wearing what that boy
is saying all these things that really
at the end of the day it's like a false
reality that people have created that
it's really it's a false perception of
life is why do people are more
entertained by that instead of these
more important topics that we're talking
about I think to some extent all of us
are like that to some extent and it's
hard to avoid things that are happening
around us in the world the basic thing
you know the basic matter boils down to
what you can see in what you can't right
when we talk about God the Creator the
sustainer the provider we talk about the
afterlife we talk about one's purpose in
life and where they're going after they
go into the ground and all of these
sorts of things these are all matters of
not the scene but the unseen and these
are not matters what people see their
actions they don't see the consequences
of things like not praying or things
like eating whatever they want or saying
whatever they want they don't see those
consequences right away right and even
people who warn them about these things
say the real consequences of these are
coming much later right so somebody lies
right now their time doesn't get cut off
somebody does something wrong they don't
see the the impact of their action right
away unless they're like robbing a bank
and the cops show up or something you
know so you don't see the consequences
of your actions in this life immediately
and that's another reason to easily
procrastinate to put it off and this is
part of human nature in some sense we
love to work on things that have
immediate rewards and we like to put
things off that have long-term rewards I
mean I'll give you a simpler example not
just religion you know you have a
workout program you have a diet
program and you if you stay on this
program for 60 days or 90 days or six
months then you'll lose these many
pounds you'll feel much better about
yourself and etc etc etc you workout the
first day second day you see results or
no you don't you workout for a week you
see results not really you go for a
month you barely see any results what
most people do the goal is way too far
out there I mean people have become so
accustomed most people including
ourselves to some extent have become so
accustomed to results right away
anything that's even a little bit
long-term we say that's not for me give
me a shortcut give me something else
right the things you make reference to
often you know entertainment you know
different kinds of company and partying
and all this kind of stuff what is it
it's instant gratification I need I want
something to happen for me it's
happening right away I don't want to
wait for it to happen and this is at the
heart of the problem you know the the
the human problem of not having enough
patience and wanting to go just just
thinking the now live in the moment and
these are actually advertising taglines
that millions of dollars are spent on
live in the moment you only live once
you know obey your thirst and whatever
right these are people that get PhDs in
marketing and come up with these small
tag lines which actually become
philosophies for people to live you can
I have friends who's probably your old
their whole life you can summarize as
they obey their thirst that's all
they're just the sprite walking around
you know that's what they are so what we
have to instill into ourselves into the
company around us and slowly our friends
people that we know is this idea that
there's more to life than just these
immediate pleasures that you're pursuing
that leave you empty anyway you know
we're gonna try to just jump around cuz
time is short
yeah hopefully one of the things that we
discussed will resonate with some people
because some people be able to relate to
one thing rather than another like the
letter that we got that we discussed on
the show from the sister
who got caught off guard or on guard and
she got let away and she was hypnotized
by the guy remember that letter she was
asking for advice what to do gave her
some wonderful advice and from that
of hers and you giving a humble uh by
the permission of the creator that
advice so many other people got to
benefit so listen let's talk about the
sisters you know a little bit and our
sisters in humanity the sisters in
humanity who now a lot of times are
seeking the attention instead of from
the crater that heavens an earth they're
seeking intention from the boys so
instead of wearing more they're wearing
less and you'll see one person who came
up to me said man I just saw my family
member you know on Facebook and I
couldn't believe it how do I you know
talk to her do some kind of show I can
Center this video because when I saw her
she was like this and everything was off
and I knew her when she was 13 14 and
now let's give her a name jazz okay
you know she's short enough for me it
might have been something else but his
jazz right so jazz is like this it's up
here that in the other and he's like man
he feels so saddened in the heart
because he knows that she's gonna get
eaten by the wolves man is out for one
thing he's hungry and she's going to be
just a captive enslaved and a prisoner
that's out there in this scandalous
society my advice to my sister's is it's
complicated and it's it's difficult for
me to talk about especially because I'm
a father and I have four daughters
myself and my daughters are getting
bigger and bigger actually my 10 year
olds running around here somewhere and
it's something I think about and worry
about a lot scary huh yeah it is it is
very scary but we have to in one of the
things that our religion anchors us in
is to not get caught up in the symptoms
and to understand the disease understand
the disease yeah and so like the way
somebody dresses the way somebody talks
the behavior these are all symptoms
that's not targeting the disease so for
instance telling you know some of the
viewers that are watching this may have
teenage kids that were brought up
religiously and then they hit a certain
point in life and then they just became
a different person all of a sudden and
now you can't control how your daughter
dresses or where your son goes and
things like that and you try to get the
mom to give a hug but about how
important a job is and how important you
know good company is and how you know
what those things do just fall on deaf
ears why because you're trying to target
a symptom and you're not
dressing a disease the the disease is
something that can't be discovered
without conversation the more especially
with Muslim youth and Muslims that are
kind of off the beaten path and you
can't even tell sometimes if they're
Muslim or not from the way they're
dressed it's really easy to pass
judgment and it's really hard to slow
down and sit each of these people down
and actually have a heart-to-heart
conversation and say what's going on why
do you think this is a good good way to
go and you'll hear things like I can do
whatever I want I'm a free person you
can't tell me what to do and you'll eat
all these arguments and you know what
respectfully hear those arguments and
try to address each one of them one at a
time
and they they should be addressed this
way one of the biggest at least
phenomenon that I've seen among sisters
that have left a modest lifestyle I'll
just put it mildly that have left a
modest lifestyle and have chosen a
different way of living among Muslim
sisters the one of the most common
things I've seen is isolation they have
low self-esteem
there were people constantly putting
them down they had in some cases
actually recently I've been saw a father
telling his daughter that she's too ugly
nobody's going to marry her this and
that and father's telling her that I
mean the place you're supposed to gain
yourself esteem is the place her
self-esteem is being destroyed you know
then there's matters of feeling judged
like you know I you know everybody has
good days and bad days right so she has
a bad day and she doesn't wear hijab and
all the sisters around her pounce on her
like you know what are you doing this is
so wrong etc etc and she says these
people are so judgmental and she just
distances herself from what would have
been good company anyway and we
sometimes even in our talks and our
lectures talk about those people in a
way that even further distances them we
want we don't want to just tell them
they're doing something wrong that much
is in my argument is most of them
already know that that's wrong our
purpose is not to judge but our purpose
is to find ways to soft and hearts to
bring them back we do want to be honest
about the message I don't want to water
down the conversation but at the same
time we have to first kind of feel for
these people and especially their
families to not be impatient and
impulsive make time for these people and
don't
don't cut them off they were they're
already cut off enough you know and it's
the love we got to love that's how we're
doing it we love them don't we
of course that's what we're sharing
because we care we wrapped up with more
here on the Dean show in Paradise
there's no death yeah you know there's
no sickness no sickness in a world of
peace and tranquility no walls no
fighting no fighting anything that you
want yeah never you can have it yeah
in the end of paradise yeah and God
wants us to have that but the price we
have to pay is give up
[Music]
when the outside everything looks good
you see the hundred thousand dollar car
you see a lot of diamonds you see a lot
of females and they think that this is
you know this is the life this is this
is like no paradise right here on earth
to go into someone's heart to change
their heart your job is to topi what the
truth is and the ally of it is while
we're sitting here I'm sitting here
constantly paying for the disease the
cure was free back here on the Dean show
with no men Ali Khan inshallah God
willing that if we're still alive we can
look back at some of these and we all
know the creditor has ever accepted
maybe we'll be old man with gray hair
I'm already getting some of you like uh
you remember the time yeah so tell us
now can men and women can boys and girls
can they be friends can the girl like
have this this confidence that look I'm
just gonna hang out with the guy and you
know the girls they're jealous of me you
know they give me a problem he's nice to
me actually he praises me he's always
telling me sweet things he's so nice you
know I'm not gonna do nothin with them
we're just hanging out connect and this
happened is this is this music and how
it's happening uh-huh that's for sure
it shouldn't happen that's also for sure
but can it be that we're just friends is
it gonna stay like you can met boys and
girls be friends no no boys know that
all too well they won't admit it but
it's they know that very well sometimes
girls don't and that's what I worry
about for my you know my sister is my
daughter's is that sometimes they don't
realize the the the elaborate scheming
of men elaborate scheming of men yeah
the world were just meeting because you
know we're lab partners or huh we're
discussing a project or the MSA the
convention we're discussing Islam you
know and the sister won't see through it
at all sometimes and actually we have to
raise the level of awareness and caution
among our sisters so that they it's
there's no harm you're going to enter
with men that's gonna happen right and
in the business world in the school
setting at the at the work setting it's
gonna happen you are gonna have
interaction but what are the what are
some guidelines that you have to respect
that can make those interactions healthy
as opposed to unhealthy I actually
personally believe we should have guided
interactions between brothers and
sisters especially young boys and young
girls as they're coming up guided by the
elders so they know how to respectfully
interact with one another also because
in in you know in this society if we try
to for example if I cut my my daughters
off and they don't ever talk to anybody
else right eventually they will go to
college eventually they will go out in
the workplace or they'll go to the
airport or travel or this and that and
there will be other people around I
don't want them to be shocked when they
see they're at the outside world you
know keeping our children in a bubble is
not going to save them but at the same
time letting them loose and saying hey
do your thing that's also insanity we
have to find a way of guiding
interactions between brothers and
sisters especially boys and girls even
teenage boys and girls and things like
that it's okay if they have an
interaction with each other so long as
it's respectful and the boys are trained
where to keep their gaze and how to keep
the conversation business only and how
to you know how to make sure they
recognize when they're crossing a line
and the elders are supposed to be there
to guide those conversations a lot of
times in youth settings even in
religious youth settings there's no
older figure shepherding the
conversation or shepherding the
interaction like youth groups exist and
the guys and the girls they're all a
bunch of teenagers and they're running
their own thing because youth should be
leaders well hell yes in most things but
in some things you guys are ridiculous
and you need you need elder elder people
to be their older folks to be there as
far as you know this like unnecessary
interaction between men and women
especially you know where this happens
this happens with people that you spend
a lot of time with so you go to college
with some people or you go to work with
some people and you know there's lime
genders just you know meetings and this
and that and it's regular and what that
does it gives check on an opportunity to
maybe not convince you one time but take
hammer away at you one percent at a time
and it
you know until it becomes a very very
big problem just the other day I got a
phone call it was one of the most
there's a very typical phone call
usually I don't take these kind of phone
calls but this time I just said I was in
a bad mood so I took it so guy calls me
says you know I'm going to this college
and there's this girl she takes all the
classes I take actually it's the other
way around I'm pretty sure but that's
nice that he put it that way you know so
she takes all the classes I take yeah
uh-huh and you know we we discussed
classes and work and career because
she's in the same major
and you know I've we've been talking for
a couple of years I haven't done
anything wrong as like yeah sure you
haven't and and then he says you know
but she just told me the other day that
you know she's considering a proposal
and my heart sunk and I don't know what
to do
what should I do and this guy is like in
just this deep shock but she proposed
like did you propose to her
there's no we were just friends I didn't
realize we were more than that until she
said there's a proposal so I started
getting attached yeah and I said dude
what do you want to do you just go yeah
what do you want to let me talk to her
parents go but there's already another
proposal and she's I think she likes the
guy or something I you know I don't even
see what life is worth living anymore
and Lala knows our okay here's the first
thing you do go tell your parents I'm
just like 21 22 years old go tell your
parents and he says no I can't they'll
kill me and that's it okay
so you can't live without her but you
can't you're not man enough to tell your
parents no why were you spending so much
time with her I just liked her she was a
real friend she used to listen to me
blah blah blah all this stuff look if
you're gonna go around
did you know religious he asked him
Plateau did you know religiously what
you're doing is wrong going out with her
and sitting and having fries at
McDonald's is wrong you knew that or no
yeah well now you know why Allah says
don't do it because it hurts you know
there are consequences of this in the
affero but emotionally people get
scarred people get really messed up
they don't realize the price they pay
emotionally even in this world I would
argue even it's not fair to the people
that these kinds of individuals will
eventually marry because they're not
emotionally attached purely to the
person they married they've their mind
is somewhere else and they're
reminiscing about somebody else you know
and it's not fair to another person so
even from an emotional point of view
it's unfair you know this the the other
thing is in this culture of dating and
you know seeing somebody and then you
don't not seeing them that you're seeing
somebody else and things like that you
just learn to become insensitive to
other people's feelings you just at the
end of the day you just turn into a
customer looking out for yourself first
time a guy gets dumped he's depressed
the next time is like I'm gonna be the
one doing the dumping mm-hmm you know so
you just I'd rather not be hurt myself
I'd rather you know be dishing out and
taking you know so you just become more
and more inhumane and that leaves you
incapable of having a family because at
the heart of family is love and
compassion and courtesy and worry about
somebody else you become bankrupt of
those feelings as a result of these like
petty petty relationships shallow
relationships absolutely did you get to
see a video that some not yet Muslims
made and we say not yet Muslims because
everyone has the potential to admit to
the one creator and not his creation
that's what a Muslim is so they did some
video on a college campus and the topic
was can boys and girls be friends did
you get a chance to see and they were
interviewing say hey what do you think
you know can you just be to the guys you
think you just be friends with the girls
and it's like at the end no and it's a
very interesting video so they see it's
not just coming from our perspective
it's coming people notice ability
obvious truths yeah okay so would you
say look Islam that that total and
complete adherence to what God Almighty
the creator wants us to do is the best
self-defense from many of these evil
vices you do Islam you avoid alcoholism
you do Islam you vote gambling you do
Islam you avoid these heartbreaks and
all the things that just flip your life
upside down so by doing what God wants
us to do is the belt best self-defense
because an ounce of prevention is better
than a pound of cure yeah I I would say
that but I would also say you know
somebody could
than here the counter-argument well a
lot of Muslims are into these things
they have Islam mm-hmm Aslam lives in
people when they're they have
reinforcements what young people
especially need is to surround
themselves with other people that are
trying to protect themselves also
they're trying to guard their chastity
their dignity their shame their religion
at the same time you know you could you
could have only Muslim friends and still
be the most messed up person in the
world there's plenty of that going
around
right so picking your friends carefully
and picking friends that will safeguard
your own Islam this is actually the key
Islam itself of course is the solution
but Islam lives in people Islam doesn't
live in books
it lives in people so you to find people
that are living it and to surround
yourself with them is is I would argue
the best defense we're gonna be right
back with more take a break here with no
man Ali Khan at the baina Institute on
the Dean she'll be right back
[Music]
back here on the D show with Norman
Alikhan
and we love the people salaam says love
on my kind so we want to share because
we care
believe we honestly care do we yeah so
when you see these things out there
obviously you know they really as the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
he said if you see an evil change it
with your hand if not speak against it
and the least amount is to hit in your
heart so when you see a lot of these
things that aren't good for the human
beings it of such you it saddens you so
we hope by doing these programs that
people will listen they meant to benefit
they'll implement some of these advices
so they can save themselves from these
heart breaks woman cannot get used and
abused by men man can not end up saving
himself from just being an animal out
there on the hunt and why are men like
this Allah says in the Quran that the
most potent desire put inside men was
desire for women Allah says is the
kratos's a lot to me he made a list of
things that we are tempted by what's
this list so first one I'll say the
Arabic in the English publisher how
Atman and the desire of our love of
temptation and desire that comes out of
women well Ben Dean and having sons our
manpower that is to save in well on a
field makan Ptolemy need to have a hobby
well filled by and piled up hoards of
gold and silver which just means wealth
we want to have tons and tons and tons
of savings even if we can if we even if
we don't live long enough to spend all
the wealth we have we'd still like to
have piles upon piles when Adam and we'd
like to have in old language to
translation would be cattle but cattle
was what it was your business back in
the day right people love having
business and they're discussing their
business what do people talk about in
their break work the new technology
that's coming out
the new trends at the hospital the new
that you know if you're a doctor they're
talking about the new medical trends if
you're a techie you're talking about the
new updates to the software to the new
language that's coming out of the new
trends in you know app development or
whatever right this is your own and then
what health which is the crop now what
is the cattle used for it's used to
produce the crop right so the return on
investment is the health so people love
you know the the desire for women and
then Sons manpower then in a lots and
lots of wealth then how do you get that
wealth business return on investment you
know what now I'm what house this is
this is the list that was made in the
third surah of the Quran and at the top
of that list what was there women now if
you look at this list people will go
through it to any means to acquire
wealth I mean some of the most corrupt
practices in the world today are out
there as a result of multi-billion
dollar industries that don't care about
right and wrong they just care about
their bottom line and we're seeing that
in the news every day right the same if
that's the case if there's an urge
inside the human being and if there's no
guidance and he has no brakes on how he
attains that appetite
compared to an animal an animal feels
hungry a gator feels hungry
a lion feels hungry what does it eat
whatever it can catch
well it doesn't think about the
consequences or if it's gonna hurt
something else or whatever it's got an
appetite it's got to be met well what if
it comes to this temptation in men if
there's no guidance if there's no
humanity left then you will do whatever
it takes to fulfill that appetite right
and you will doesn't matter if it hurts
somebody else doesn't matter if it
corrupts and destroy society and ruins
families it none of that matters all
that matters is your urges that's the
only thing you see you don't see
anything else so I don't see any
difference between people that are you
know that are addicted to these kinds of
temptations and people that are
multibillion-dollar executives that make
you know these deals that destroy entire
villages in the third world because of
their bottom line or contaminate water
supplies and things like that because
they're gonna produce some you know some
some soda or something you know four
billion dollar billions of dollars of
profit there's no difference between
because at the end of the day you have a
desire you fulfill it and you don't care
about the consequences this is why we
are the way we are and those desires
Allah put in us but he also gave us the
brakes
that's what guidance is it holds you
back and keeps you balanced so you don't
turn into an animal when the guidance is
gone that's all you and I are then
couple points I just have to mention
before we close yeah I'm gonna ask you
about bayna and before that for the four
because we really cater to those who
know nothing about the purpose of life
you're out there she might have just
came back and you know look we keep it
real here on the D show so she came back
our show was caught late at night and
she's coming from the strip club she's a
stripper the guy is coming from the
nightclub he's smoking weed he's
drinking booze and now they tuned in and
they've watched a couple of the shows
and they like this idea of just
worshipping the crater not his creation
they're getting sick of following their
lusts and desires anybody want to change
their life but they don't know where to
start what advice do you have for him
and just ensure the I mean the fact that
they're making time to watch a video
like this one is a really good sign good
sign that yeah it's a very good sign
that you're good lies in their heart and
the first starting point would be for
any person that's immersed in a
lifestyle like that that you shouldn't
look at what you've done already in the
past and say it's too late for me
there's no such thing there's no such
thing that your yesterday will determine
what your tomorrow is going to be and we
shouldn't let that be the case also
don't let your friends and the people
around you you know determine who you
are
you are your own man you're your own
woman you can't just say everybody's
surrounded around me is a certain way
therefore I have to be this way or this
is all I know of that's not who you are
you're you're greater than all of those
things you created for a higher purpose
than all of those things making time for
just you know reflection making time for
pursuit searching more making time to
seek out people that can teach you
better is probably the first big step
anybody can take if you can find for
example a local mosque to go ask some
questions send to send you questions so
you can connect them to people that may
be in their area because that needs to
happen to tap into actually living
resources that can ask
answer questions about religion and
things like that would be the next
healthy step would be a good step in the
right direction and one thing at a time
but really you should not assume that
first of all take it seriously as you
keep saying it's an urgent matter it
shouldn't wait so if you know you've
been blessed enough to at least be
exposed to something about the message
at least give it some more time and
explore some more and find out if this
is really the right thing and if it's
the right thing for you and the second
is to give it to don't put this off
because you don't know how long you and
I are gonna be around so that we can
take proactive actions in the last
minute that we have tell us sure about
your organization the bainite Institute
the Institute is a complicated
organization which I'll simplify for you
the point of it is two things the vision
of it was to make Arabic easy for
Muslims to study and for Quran to pull
on to be made easy for Muslims to study
the point the original purpose of it was
to facilitate that education for Muslims
in America that was the original goal
hamdulillah slowly it's expanding to
around the world as the goal of the
organization grew so did some of its
goals so it's not just introductory
education in Arabic and introductory
education in the Quran but actually the
where we're sitting now on campus is
actually a pretty advanced program in
Arabic al hamdulillah it's the only one
of its kind in America where our
students are studying for a little over
nine months full-time and they're
studying the Arabic language and cello
as as best as I and my colleagues can
teach it so that they have a really good
sound grounded understanding of the
language enough that they can read the
Quran and read hadith and read Arabic or
Islamic texts in their original form
without translation and understand them
in depth this is the verbatim Word of
God the Quran the verbatim Word of God
and the word of the Prophet SAW the
hadith right so they if they're able to
get a first-hand taste of that because
you know what something's always lost in
translation and some beauty and some
depth is always missing so the point of
this training is to give students the
power to at least taste some of that
depth for themselves and then the the
idea actually the one of the first
expressions I taught in the program this
year I want to share with you is I'll
give you a small example
include your passing by it and you see a
well right and you're not that thirsty
back in the day obviously nowadays
nobody would look into a well but back
in the day you passed by well you don't
think twice about are you go on somebody
else passes by and says maybe I should
have a low so they take a little light
they dip their finger and they taste it
a little and they realize this is
actually a well and the water in it is
water from paradise from heaven it's
incredible it's nothing like they've
ever tasted ever before
now if you had a little taste what would
you want to do you'd want to get more
the guy who never got the first taste to
begin with what would he do just go on
his way
he wouldn't even think twice right the
point here is you know to give students
a little bit of a taste and if I can do
that successfully if my colleagues can
do that about less permission then what
will they do they'll take a second dip
and a third on their own you know and
the people who never embark on this
journey
they won't never know what they're
missing out on so that's that's the
that's the beauty of you know this
language and the beautiful book that
Allah has given us the more we explore
it the more beautiful we find it so
people can find you there bayna calm but
you know calm thank you once again may
the creator of the heavens and earth
rewards you for being anonymous thank
you so much for coming we're really
happy to have you here come the students
are happy to see you and shall let me
get time to interact with you afterwards
also thank you very much and thank you
sincerely for being with us here on the
Dean show it's not too late until death
comes death is a reality so take this
moment that you have in life that God
Almighty has given you and do a God
Almighty wants from you ask him for the
guidance he sent messengers to our time
to guide humanity and they came with the
guidance last the final messenger sent a
man kind of problem Hamid peace be upon
him it's all there he's been preserved
as been saved Quran the verbatim Word of
God
it's the blueprint for mankind but if
you don't know it how you're gonna live
it and if you don't ask how shall you
receive so do it right now
call on God alone not his creation we
don't need 999 from you to send your
genie in a bottle just send you some
lucky charm no we just need you to ask
the Creator simple request guide me
guide me guide me and he also facilitate
a way give us a call at
any other further questions we'll see
you next time god-willing until then
peace be unto you